ừ nói chung về git
đi
À hôm nay chứ hôm nay n qu mắt hôm nay
sẽ nói chung về git này Hôm nay buổi 3
đúng không
Ờ
ừ hít cách mà còn gì nữa nhở chế là mình
sẽ bổ sung cái này
sau Alo chào các bạn ạ
ạ
thng thỉ thoảng mình cứ phả vào thử mic
trước
Ờ ch bạn thì hôm nay trước khi vào vào
buổi kiểu mình live livestream code đây
để để để mình mình ghi
rõ hôm
nay sẽ lại tiếp tục live code
về lật trình web bán hàng
à thực tế
các bạn có thắc mắc tâm sự gì
ừ hôm nay thì mình sẽ dạy
kiểu chỉ qua các bạn biết về cách nữ cả
git cách mình sử dụng như nào
Ờ có bạn hỏi về design pattern đã cả
repository
ờ Thực ra thì hôm trước tôi có tôi có
chia sẻ đó là tôi lúc đầu tôi định dạy
các bạn về điều đấy Kiểu nhưng mà nhưng
mà bản thân chính tôi kiểu khi đi làm
thì đến thời điểm hiện tại thì vẫn chưa
áp dụng một cách triệt để lắm
và leader của tôi gần đây mới đang đập
đi xây lại
cái dự án để mà làm lại theo kiểu dạng
design pattern này xong rồi
Ờ xong rồi Kiểu nói chung là nó theo một
cái hướng gì đó kiểu dạng là từng layer
rõ ràng hơn
ấy thì
ờ Tôi cảm thấy là cái cái việc đấy thì
thì bản thân mình chỉ cần biết qua về
khái niệm và codt theo chứ thực ra là
mình cũng không cần
phải dùng từ không cần phải không đúng
mình không thể đổ đổ cái trách nhiệm đấy
cứ chỉ cho leader được nhưng mà nhưng mà
có bài toán thực tế ở đây nhá Đó là một
là ông vào hẳn một cái dự án mà đã có
một cái design button rồi thì ông sẽ
code theo cái đấy hai là ông vào cái dự
án mà nó code nó cũng kiểu cũng tạp nham
the kiểu là xử lý hết ở trong
controller xử kiểu kiểu kiểu thế hoặc là
thậm chí là còn dùng pp thuần nữa thì
còn tệ hơn tôi mà bây giờ mấy ông bảo
tôi là kiểu vào pp thuần ngồi cốt thì
chắc là tôi sẽ nghỉ luôn Thôi không vào
code được kiểu đấy nhưng mà nghĩa là chỉ
là cái cái đấy cò phụ thuộc khá nhiều
vào cái dự án mà ông sẽ tham gia vào
nghĩa phụ thuộc vào khá Nhu nhiều V
người đi trước và tập thể chứ không phải
kiểu ông nghĩ ra một cái design button
Hoặc là ông tham khảo được cái design
buton ở trên mạng rồi ông ốp về là tất
cả mọi người theo được Ông đúng không ạ
thế này khó nên là nên là đấy là một cái
đấy một cái mà tôi cảm thấy là
kiểu mình không cần phải chú trọng biết
quá rõ về cái des buton và gọi là mình
chỉ cần biết nắm rõ lý thuyết theo kiểu
theo kiểu này
leader của tôi bây giờ à Kiểu đề xuất
làm cái design button này thì anh em
code theo cái design button đấy thôi ok
nghĩa HM chỉ anh em cũng hiểu qua về
cách viết op lẫn cả các layer các thứ
chia rõ ràng chứ không cần phải hiểu xâu
hơn vì vì cái việc đấy thì đúng là như
tôi vừa bảo đó là leader may ra họ có
thể thay đổi được cả một cái dự án cả
toàn bộ anh em phải theo họ chứ bây giờ
tính ra anh em mình thì vẫn chỉ Junio
cùng lắm là có ông xo ở đây ngồi nghe
tôi chém gió chứ cũng chưa lên đến cái
mức độ cao hơn nếu mức độ cao hơn thì
thực ra là không không ngồi nghe tôi làm
gì cả vì họ cũng biết cách cần phải làm
gì
rồi Thế nên là tôi chia sẻ Thật là bản
thân tôi cũng không dành về mấy cái đấy
lắm để mà có thể dạy cho mấy ông và tôi
nghĩ tôi nghĩ là
là mình chưa cần
phải chưa cần phải kiểu biết quá rõ về
nó kiểu dạng là thực tiễn làm về nó quá
nhiều không cần vì bản chất tôi vẫn
thường hay nói mới ông là bản chất là
tôi tôi đi làm không biết là tôi may mắn
ha không Nghĩa là tôi không nắm rõ về
thuật toán lắm này thậm chí là op vẫn
chỉ và D button thì chỉ mức kiểu lý
thuyết thôi
đấy bởi vì tôi hồi học Java tôi tôi có
qua môn này nhá Nhưng mà kiểu bởi vì hồi
đấy học pp trước Java và tôi th tôi kiểu
muốn hướng theo pp ấ nên thành ra là
kiểu học Java chỉ qua môn thôi nên thành
ra là như ông kia vừa nói dùng interface
các thứ thứ hoặc là hôm trước là sếp Tôi
bảo
là nếu Giả sử mà anh mà phỏng vấn chú
vào có khi anh loại chú khi mà anh hỏi
cái câu ách class khác gì với face Các
thử các
thứ đấy Kiểu
thế nhưng mà tôi vẫn làm được việc tôi
vẫn khẳng định tôi là tôi làm được việc
theo kiểu không phải làm việc việc xông
đâu nhá mà tôi đang gánh trọng trách
cũng khá nhiều cái tính năng quan trọng
ở trên công ty và
ờ và gọi như là tôi sắp tôi được làm
nhân viên của tháng mà tôi đang Đạt đang
cố phấn đấu để đạt nhân viên của quý năm
ngoái tôi được đạt nhân viên của năm mà
đấy ng â chỉm mình làm được việc và cũng
gọi là được mọi người kiểu dạng là tin
tưởng vân vân thì tức là trình độ mình
không đến nỗi đúng không Tôi không làm
mấy cái việc kiểu lật vặt đâu nhá tôi
toàn làm những cái khá là quan trọng
nhưng mà đương nhiên thì để được như thế
thì cái sự nhiệt huyết rồi Vân Vân các
thứ mình phải đi đi kèm để đánh đổi bởi
vì là lý thuyết kiểu dạng là gọi nhỉ tư
duy lý thuyết của mình thì cũng chỉ ở
mức gọi là tương đối Tôi cảm thấy thế
Tôi cũng không phải con nhà người ta để
mà kiểu mình kiểu rất xuất sắc rất là
giỏi mình phải bù lại cái gì à cân C bù
siêng năng à cần cù bù thông minh đúng
không đấy
Ờ nên là tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ dạy cho các
bạn ở mức là các bạn hiểu tự Duy lập
trình có những cái sẽ tách ra hôm nay
tôi sẽ tách code xử lý các các thứ thứ
ra thì các bạn sẽ thấy là hôm trước là
xử lý ở trong controller đúng không Tôi
sẽ tách ra một chỗ khác nhưng nó không
hẳn là một cái des Pon quá ngon quá kiểu
gọi là gọi nhở Thực ra thì Hữa trước tôi
có đi cái sự kiện người ta bảo là chẳng
có một cái design button nào là chuẩn cả
Chẳng có một kiểu bản chất là nó cũng
mvc mà lên kiểu dạng là kiểu chẳng qua
nó vứt ra một cái chỗ nào đó khác thôi
chứ nếu
mà Chứ không ai có thể Kền chê việc code
của người này kiểu trông kiểu gọi không
clean đúng không và code mình clean hơn
chẳng chẳng ai thể kiểu so sánh chơi ba
nhau kiểu thế cả mỗi người sẽ có một cái
tông code riêng mà đúng
không thì tôi sẽ chỉ cho mấy ông cái
tông code của tôi như thế nào thì mấy
ông có thể tham
khảo và quan trọng nhất vẫn là tư duy
mình khi mà mấy ông sửa cái đoạn code
đấy mấy ông hiểu được là mình và nhớ
được là mình cần phải sửa chỗ nào đấy
điều quan trọng chứ Bây giờ giả sử code
ông rất là xịn nhưng mà kiểu khi bảo ông
mò lại để sửa ông không biết chỗ nào để
sửa thì cái design buton của ông chả có
cái ý nghĩa gì cả đúng chứ
Đấy toàn bộ mấy cái kiểu dạng Xây dựng
hệ thống code cho nó kiểu chuyên nghiệp
hơn mà chính mình còn chẳng hiểu được
cái chuyên nghiệp đấy chính mình còn khó
sực ử cái đấy thì tự ông làm khó ông
thôi đúng không đấy nên là tôi nghĩ
là là không cần phải suy nghĩ quá phức
tạp về cái vụ thiết kế các thứ code sao
cho mình tiện nhất mình hiểu nhất về nó
Và thậm chí Và thậm chí đó là đồng
nghiệp của ông phải hiểu với nó nếu mà
ông cốt xịn quá ông cốt ngầu quá đúng
không đồng nghiệp ông không hiểu một cái
gì cả khi đọc đoạn code của ông đấy thì
cũng dở mấy ông hiểu bài toán đây không
Đôi khi bị thế đấy nhá Ờ hồi trước larel
từng có bị cho cái vụ đấy Đó là có nhiều
hàm bu in heer quá Xong rồi thành ra là
cái người mà mới học à Mới học pp rồi
chuyển quá lel ấy người ta không được
thực hành nhiều lại về về kiểu
à Thứ nhất là SQL Này ông sẽ thấy là làm
lael thì không kiểu động và SQL mấy nữa
kiểu gần như là gọi các hàm của nó thôi
đúng không Đấy thứ hai là
à Thứ hai là kiểu nó có nhiều hàm ẩn
heer quá các thứ thứ mình không dùng
kiểu dạng thuần nữa heer nó hỗ trợ tận
răng rồi chẳng hạn thế đấy thì thì người
mới người ta sẽ kiểu sẽ bị choáng bởi có
rất nhiều hàm họ lại phải đọc lại xem
hàm này Thực ra nó là cái gì người mới
học pp đã bị choáng bởi hàm của P pp rồi
chưa học xong hàm pp giờ còn phải học
happer của lel nữa đấy Kiểu thế
Ờ mà ông hiểu gì tôi không ạ Ờ ông nào
kiểu dạng làm lel một thời gian Chắc là
ông sẽ hiểu bởi Hồi trước tôi đi dạy tôi
bị cấm Nếu mà tôi dạy larel ấ thì tôi bị
cấm dùng mấy cái heer lẫn cả dùng que
builder lẫn cả El mà tôi bắt buộc phải
ra hết để cho sinh viên kiểu
còn gọi là hiểu và gọi là ôn lại kiến
thức về SQL
vụ có bạn hỏi về cái vụ này chia sẻ về
design button được không
à Có học môn này trên trường mà Mung
lung quá thì tôi vừa nói đấy Đó là chắc
là tôi sẽ không chia sẻ được bạn đấy vì
bản thân thì tôi cũng không dành tôi
cũng chỉ biết mỗi lý thuyết
và và đúng là học trên trường để biết lý
thuyết thôi và để mà em thực hành nhiều
hơn thì chắc là như bạn kia vừa nói chắc
là làm Java nhiều em ạ là g va nhiều thì
em sẽ nắm rõ
hơn
ờ đúng là Java ông sẽ học chặt chẽ hơn
về cả op các thứ thứ nữa
Ờ anh có nghĩ về việc tăng số bổ live
trong một tuần không tôi không hẳn
là định định dạy cho các ông kiểu thực
ra buổi này vừa like code vừa để tâm sự
mỏng qua một ít gọi là như nào nhỉ cũng
gọi
là trong những cái khoảng thời gian này
thôi Tôi không chắc là thứ nhất là chắc
chắn là tôi sẽ không livestream nhiều
hơn thứ hai là về sau kiểu ví dụ ở Sang
năm thì lúc mà
tôi kiểu chuẩn bị đi dạy học lại bên FBT
chắc là tôi cũng sẽ khó mà livestream
lại được nữa ờ À livestream tiếp được
nữa Bởi vì tôi vẫn làm full time ở trên
công ty thì khi đi dậy sẽ dậy và những
cái giờ như này này thì chắc là sẽ khó
mà kiểu Ờ kh mà tiếp tục có thể kiểu
livestream được
đâu tôi lại cảm thấy kiểu khi đi dạy
xong tôi lại cảm thấy hao hứng hơn thì
tôi có thể like code vào cuối tuần thì
kiểu chủ nhật chẳng hạn mấy ông hoàn
toàn có thể xem lại không cần phải tương
tác livestream cũng được đúng
Ờ Thực ra là fan bây giờ thì mấy ông nên
nếu thật sự mấy ông ông chỉ làm fen mấy
ông biết
ra biết ra Script theo kiểu FB này CS
thì biết cắt gép và một tí design này
đấy thế lương của fen ở công ty tôi cũng
cao ấy nhá bằng luôn cả anh em làm làm
kiểu backen bình thường luôn trừ mấy anh
mấy anh em kiểu leader senio thì đươ
nhiên cao hơn hẳn rồi
Ờ anh like code à live Project nữ À đây
cũng không hẳn là tính là một Project
đâu Đây là dự án kiểu đây nó nó làm một
cái dự án thực tế hơn làm một cái pet
Project một cái kiểu dự án cá nhân gì gì
đó không
phải Ok Ờ Bây giờ trả lời qua vài cái
tôi định tâm sự với bạn một các bạn một
tí hoặc cuối buổi tâm sự tôi không biết
à tôi lưu cái link này lâu lắm thôi Tôi
mới xem lại
Ờ tôi cho mấy ông xem cái này hay phết
kìu bạn này là bạn đồng nghiệp ở cùng
công ty tôi hôm đấy bạn đấy Kiểu
kiểu đang làm cái phần xong rồi kéo code
kéo code về thấy là tôi mới chỉnh sửa
các thứ tôi làm vụ tối ưu là nhiều mà
đấy thì tôi mới bảo kiểu tôi cũng kiêm
nhiều cái quan trọng phết tối ưu ở trang
thành T án mấy không ạ Lúc đầu nó tận 3
giây Chẳng hiể sao mấy ông thì tưởng
tượng vào trang thanh toán ông load 3
giây mới ra được cái
Trang thì trải nghiệm nó khá là tệ và CR
tức cả conversion rate tức cả tỉ lệ
chuyền đổi Nghĩa là nghĩa là hiểu là n
ná kiểu rằng là tỉ lệ giữa việc
ông vào và ông thanh toán là bao nhiêu
phần trăm ấy thì hồi đấy CR của công ty
tôi bị giảm bởi vì chắc là có liên quan
đến cả việc và Trang Thanh toán nó bị
lag gì gì đó nên là tôi ngồi tối ưu lại
tôi tối ưu lại nhanh phết đấy nhá Tối ưu
lại hơn lúc đầu là hơn b 3 4 giây t tù
yêu là hơn 1 giây hơn 1 giây thôi đấy
ngồi chỉnh sửa bao nhiều thừ thử đấy thì
thì em này mới vào xem xong rồi bà Em ấy
cũng làm cái làm lại làm thêm cái tính
năng gì gì đó xong rồi thấy là tôi cũng
sửa cái đoạn ngay trên trước đó về cái
logic lấy lấy dữ liệu ra rồi thì thì
cách tôi lấy thì sẽ là kiểu cách lại rồi
các thứ thứ cũng là cái hôm nay có thể
tôi sẽ
dạy thì em đấy tham khảo và muốn kiểu
chỉnh sửa lại code logic của em đấy theo
cách của tôi Nghĩa Thực ra thực tế là em
ấy hoàn toàn không thể nhắn không cần
nhắn tin này code bây giờ code và code
của chúng ta đúng không Thì cứ lấy về mà
dùng thôi nhưng mà nhưng mà em ấy nhắn
kiểu này hay kiểu Tôi cảm thấy kiểu kiểu
chắc là không biết mình có tính là kiểu
thích nịnh hay không nhưng mà nói chung
là kiểu Đây cũng là tin nhắn đầu tiên
luôn kiểu khá là khá là kiểu dạng là
biết kỹ năng chắc là kỹ năng mềm Tôi cảm
thấy là tốt đấy nên là tôi cũng kiểu
dạng là cảm thấy muốn hỗ trợ em đấy n
nên là tôi bảo là tôi sẽ xem lại à em
đấy cứ đẩy đoạn code lên để đi để để tôi
sẽ hỗ trợ và tôi sửa lại đoạn code của
em đấy luôn cho
n 700.000 để tiếp cận để
ba không nhu cầu lắm
Ờ cái video này là gì tôi không biết đâu
tôi sợ bấm vào bây giờ nhảy ra cái gì
không chắc là không có gì đâu nhưng mà
tôi chắc là để sau hôm nay tôi thực ra
hôm nay m tâm sự một tí về cái này tôi
định tâm sự Cái này ở cuối buổi cơ nhưng
mà tôi thường mấy ngày hôm nay mấy ông
thấy mấy video trước dạy khá là sâu kiểu
khá là cuốn kiểu gì mà toàn hai tiếng
nên tôi không Lúc ấy hết sử hơi để mà
tâm sự một cái gì đó thôi nên tôi xin
phép tâm sự sớm bây
Ừ Thực ra
là tôi mới nốt lại cái này là để mà hôm
nay bởi vì hôm nay là tôi nhắn tin cho
khá nhiều anh em kiểu Chính xác là chủ
yếu là các em sinh viên Hồi trước để mà
rủ kiểu có dịp mai làm một cái dịp sự
kiện thôi chắc là tôi lại quảng bá cái
sự kiện này cho dù tôi cảm cảm thấy
chẳng ăn được cái gì từ đy
ờ cái sự kiện mấy ông đây thỉnh thoảng
tôi cứ phải nhắc lại mấy ông có một cái
Channel
là là lên kèo thì mai tôi đi cái sự kiện
này này ở Hà Nội thì tôi
đó rủ anh em đi kiểu dạng là đi sự kiện
cùng nhau xong rồi ăn uống các
thứ thì hôm nay có có vẻ là tôi nhắn
nhiều Face và lượng người phản hồi lại
Ờ nó kiểu đấy conion rate đúng không khá
là thấp rất là thấp không được như kỳ
vọng đấy
dần dần dần khó mà kiểu giữ thân được
với nhau mình có công việc riêng cuộc
sống riêng nên là kiểu Ừm sẽ có lúc mà
mình rủ nhau mà kiểu bởi vì hôm nay tôi
cầm là tôi chia sẻ ông hai mấy ông Hai
bài học xức máu đó thứ nhất là đôi khi
mấy ông rủ như thế m ông đừng có tạo
nhóm tôi tạo nhóm rồi tôi nhắn luôn vào
trong đấy Kiểu để nhóm chat đấy Kiểu hơn
tầm mười mấy người để tôi muốn là kiểu
thông bào chung ấy thành ra nhược điểm
mà kiểu một ông mà kiểu muốn rút là tự
nhiên kiểu nó bị Hữu ứng là kiểu nhiều
người muốn rút đấy thứ
hai đó
là ông tạo nhóm chat như thế xong rồi
tôi bấm cái nút kiểu tạo cái bình chọn
ấy ở trên nhóm chat trên Messenger ấy
tôi không hề biết được cái bình chọn đấy
có người khác có thể thêm cái lựa chọn
của họ vào và cái bình mang tiếng là
bình chọn nhưng mà có thể chọn được
nhiều ạ Đấy x tự nhên đầu tiên tôi tạo
hai lựa chọn là đi sự kiện và đi ăn
Đấy thế mà tự nhiên có một ông thêm vào
là không đi đấy rồi cùng thì mọi kiểu
hơn 10 người tích và không
đi đy tốt nhất là
không không nên tạo cái mình chọn ở trên
trên Facebook nếu mà ông muốn rủ như thế
tôi lúc sau Tôi ân hận quá Lỡ rồi nên
sau sú kinh nghiệm Tôi sẽ tạo một cái
event ở trên Facebook Xong rồi để chế độ
riêng tư xong rồi chỉ xong rồi ẩn đi
người khác có thể xem được danh sách mới
đấy Xong rồi ấn mời bạn bè đấy các thứ
rồi đăng trong đấy đăng trong đấy tôi
cảm thấy nó sẽ có tiện hơn là kiểu nó sẽ
không bị Spam tin
nhắn rất phù hợp việc là ai chụp cái gì
ai đăng cái gì đó thì đăng lại vào trong
cái sự kiện đấy thậm chí ngày này năm
xưa nó C nhắc mình là mình từng đi sự
kiện này hình như thế không biết Nói
chung là tôi cảm thấy là tạo sự kiện ở
trên đấy thì cái việc là người khác tích
vào có đi hoặc là từ chối Hình như là
chỉ mình mình thấy không biết được tí
rồi phải test lại
là tự nhiên kiểu một người tạo cái kiểu
không đi thi một loạt ông tích tích tích
vào không đi
kiểu từng cái tích vào không đi đấy Kiểu
lòng mình đau thêm ấ thà thà không ai
tích vào cái gì Kiểu như thế còn đỡ hơn
việc kiểu tất cả mọi người đã xem người
quán nửa tích và không đi đúng không
Đấy và lẫng cả là theo tôi thì thực sự
thì tính tôi là tôi muốn là người Kiểu
kiểu dạng là mình cầu nối để kết nối
giữa mọi người với nhau như thế nhưng có
vẻ là việc giữ đấy và truyền lửa đấy nó
khá là khó là nên là tôi cũng nghĩ dần
là
việc cái việc đấy có thể không phù hợp
với mình lắm
càng Thế mình sẽ ít Hòa hùa hay hòa theo
đám đông mình không thực sự là thích đi
cùng tập thể Đông nữa mà mình sẽ chỉ có
một một kiểu một vài bạn thân kiểu một
nhóm bạn thân kiểu vài người thôi mấy
ông nghĩ thế không Tôi không biết mấy
ông có có bạn thân hay không nhưng mà về
tôi thì tôi
cũng tôi Thực sự tôi không biết khái
niệm bạn thân của tôi kiểu bây giờ là
như nào nữa vì hồi trước thì từng nghĩ
là có có bạn thân đấy nhưng mà nhưng mà
Đúng là lâu anh em không còn nói chuyện
hay tương tác với nhau nên là cũng
à cũng không biết là còn thân nữa không
thì vì chuẩn là thân thì mình phải hiể
cũng tương đối hiểu nhau đúng
cọn mình còn là con trai thì chắc là
kiểu mình
sẽ mình sẽ không kiểu thổ lộ ra cái suy
nghĩ hay mọi thứ tâm sự
nhiều cho dù là cho dù là con trai hay
con gái thì vẫn
cần vẫn cần tâm sự vẫn cần kiểu có cảm
xúc mà đúng không Chúng ta không vô cảm
đấy Nên là thế nên là tôi mới Tôi cảm
tôi tôi nghĩ thế nên thành ra tôi mới
thường haay nói về mấy ông ấy ngay Ngay
cả ngay cả cái tôi hay nhắn mấy ông ấy
đó là tôi thường ấy không chỉ nói là mấy
ông có câu hỏi gì thì nhắn tôi tôi
thường hay nói thêm là mấy ông có tâm sự
gì chia sẻ gì không biết không biết chia
sẻ với ai thì có thể chia sẻ với tôi tôi
Thực ra tôi không phải là con người
à Tôi không phải con người đồng cảm giỏi
Tôi cũng không phải con người đưa lời
khuyên tốt nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là là Ừ thì
đôi khi mấy ông
sẽ sẽ cảm thấy thoải mái và dễ chịu hơn
khi mà Ít ra có người lắng nghe mình
đúng không ạ Ít nhất là có người có một
người nà Đó lắng nghe mình có thể người
đấy người lạ có đôi khi người lạ cũng
hay thật đôi khi ông tâm sự với người lạ
có khi hay mấy ông cốt để chút ra thôi
chứ thực ra là cũng không cần hẳn lời
khuyên hay là một cái gì đó đúng không
Mình thì đương nhiên vấn đề của mình thì
chắc là chỉ mình mới thực sự hiểu và
giải quyết được người ngoài chắc là
là kiểu nó n nà giống như là nhở giống
như là ông ông em tôi bây giờ đang bình
luận một điện hình
ờ hai anh em thì thỉnh thoảng kiểu có gì
khó chịu thì nói với nhau xong rồi Ờ
à Xong rồi kiểu chia sẻ mem với nhau
chính thế đủ vui rồi Kiểu cảm thấy cũng
được giải tỏa phần nào nghĩa là ít nhất
là ông có một người gì đ nghĩa đôi khi
không phải chia sẻ nỗi buồn Ông chia sẻ
niềm vui ông có một người để chia sẻ ông
vui rồi đúng không
đấy Anh có muốn show cam không á
Ờ hồi trước tôi đã từng nói về vụ này đó
là thực ra khi mà tôi dạy thì tôi sẽ
không muốn kiểu mấy ông tập trung vào
cái mặt tôi tập trung vào tôi đang làm
gì Ừ nhưng mà chắc là chắc thực sự là có
khi tôi sẽ khi mà tâm sự kiểu này tôi sẽ
chia sẻ màn hình để buổi sau tôi à nhầm
không phải chia sẻ màn hình chia sẻ
camera để buổi sau tôi sẽ cân nhắc tôi
sẽ chỉnh nhá Nhưng mà tôi sợ là mọi
người để ý kiểu đôi khi là có gì đó ở
đằng sau tôi mọi người nhìn thấy nó lại
không hay Chẳng hạn nghĩa là nhìn mình
thì thì không sao tôi không ngại đâu
Nhưng mà quan trọng là đằng sau mà kéo
sự là có người đi ra đi vào hay là gì gì
đó một cái cảnh gì đó Bất Ngờ Biết đâu
đấy ông không biết ông từng nhìn thấy
mấy cái chamer thỉnh thoảng có cái gì
kiểu dạng có một
cái tình huống nào đó bất ngờ xảy ra
mình không xử lý được mình lại quả đấy
lại buồn
Ờ Chứ tôi tâm sự này tôi không khóc đâuu
mấy ông không cần phải xem kiểu nghĩa là
tôi đang khóc nên tôi phải mở cam lên n
ủi à mà lỡ cả là tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ có
thể thích mở cam con này ít nhất là con
này con Macbook nên là cam nó xịn hơn
cái con cũ con cũ máy đeo cam cùi bắp
lắm là để hôm nào
nhá
sẽ phải conect việc là chỉnh chỉnh lại
được cái vụ là kiểu nó sẽ làm mờ được
cái BC background à background dịch ra
gì nhở Ừ cứ làm mở đằng sau thì tôi sẽ
mở
Bởi vì tính ra tôi ngại là ngại kiểu tự
nhiên có gì đó bất ngừa xảy ra vì tính
ra tôi đang livestream ở phòng khách chứ
không phải là livestream trong phòng
riêng đóng kến cửa Nếu mà có phòng riêng
đóng kến cửa thì tôi kiểu làm gì chẳng
được đúng không Còn Đây là kiểu nó cũng
đang hơi Tôi cảm thấy nó đang
hơi lội Thiên có sẽ có rất nhiều tình
huống bất ngờ xảy ra Ví dụ đồn ngồi
Khách Đến Chơi chẳng hạn
câu hỏi về cá nhân thì các bạn cứ ngồi
stu Tôi ở st không biết phát đâ từ đấy
đúng hay không
ờ
thẳng stock stock stock xh
chập
tra tôi ở trên à Facebook ấy nó ra hết
mà tôi không Tuy là tôi không công khai
nhưng là nó lộ lắm thích cái để tôi chỉ
mẹo cho mấy ông biết được Sinh nhật ai
đó mấy ông lên
kể cả cho dù là người đấy
không không đă gần đây thì quá khứ họ
kiểu gì đã từng được chúc mừng sinh nhật
trên trang C nhân hoặc là từng đăng rồi
trừ khi người thấy ẩn hết toàn bộ cái
bài đăng
thôi ông cứ lên Hẳng cái trang cá nhân
của họ tìm kiếm chữ sinh nhật sinh nhật
này thậm chí là snvv này đấy xin nhật
vôi vẻ đấy dẽ ra được Ngà sinh của họ dễ
mà ô chư tôi theo dõi các bạn nữ thế
suốt
chưa ạ Ờ tôi có dạy trong playlist của
tôi Có cái có cái đấy đấy ông thể nghe
qua để xem cũng tôi dạy cũng chỉ mức cơ
bản thôi nó cũng không phải là kiểu nó
chưa đủ thực tế cho lắm Vậy tôi dạy Hồi
đấy để cho mấy ông biệ để nhảy sang
faceb dạy faceb ch dễ
chứ còn à để mà ông học sâu về cái đấy
thì tôi nghĩ là thế Ra là cũng chả nơi
nào học sâu cái đấy cả học m VC giờ cũng
chỉ để để làm fmw hết theo tôi là
thế Ok bây giờ bắt đầu nhảy sang code
nhá tâm sự xong mọi thứ hết rồi
à trừ cái trừ cái này để buổi sau
đúng không
ạ Mình cũng đã làm shit cùng mình cũng
đã biết qua về sher
Factory
về code hôm trước bởi vì là bởi vì
hỏi à Hôm qua tôi hỏi được Sếp tôi về
cái lý do trang này chạy chậm
rồi xế tôi Ờ ông thấy Trang này lúc đầu
vào chạy chậm lúc sau load rất là nhanh
đúng không ạ xem tôi tôi hỏi sếp thì sếp
bảo là có thể là do C đang bị chiếm bởi
chính cái chính cái mình đang livestream
cái
obs nó làm khá là nặng kiểu chiếm
luôn chứ bình thường vào này load nhanh
đúng không Thỉnh thoảng nó sẽ kiểu bị đơ
Anh ấy nói giả thiết như thế Tôi thấy
cũng có cái hợp lý của
router not DEF
này trước mình xóa cái gì à
sửa cái À đúng rồi tôi dạy mấy ông về
ờ git đã vì tôi không Nhớ hôm trước là
mấy hôm trước từ hôm trước giờ mình
không thề đẩy code lên nên thành ra là
kiểu nó đ khá bị dài rồi mình sẽ tôi sẽ
chỉ ông cách tôi dùng kí
nhiên là đương nhiên là vẫn là mô hình
mvc rồi Nhưng ý tôi là bây giờ không làm
mvc thuần mấy nữa mà tôi thấy là dùng fw
nhiều fw t nhiên có MBC rồi
Ờ tự nhiên có cái này cái gì nhỉ Không
biết bỏ qua Ờ tôi
sẽ đầu tiên thì tôi lại nhắc lại một lần
nữa về cách tôi học git là
tôi cái dự án tính ra là công ty khi mà
về công ty này tôi mới thực sự là kiểu
kiểu dùng git nhiều hơn là kiểu biết
cách dùng hơn hồi trước thì hồi trước
thì tôi kiểu dạng là có có động vào cũng
dùng git ở công ty cũ Thì có dùng git
Chắc chắn rồi nhưng mà dùng cái phần mềm
kiểu click chuột để mà kiểu đẩy hết code
lên cũng không cũng không biết fix
Conflict hay mọi thứ là như nào nói
chung hồi đấy khá là Lom zom đúng không
thấy khá là non không tự tìm hiểu nhiều
cái Còn khi về công ty này thì đúng là
tự mình tự tìm hiểu khá nhiều thì biết
qua về git hơn và càng càng gần đây càng
biết rõ hơn một tí về
git thì đầu tiên là git là để công cụ để
mình kiểu kiểu quản lý code đúng không
Thì việc là mình để code lên thì hiện
tại thì bây giờ m ông đang thấy tôi chỉ
có một Brand cng lắm là thêm Br này của
ông em và thường cũng chỉ thường có thể
đẩy hết vào trong PR này Nếu giả sử
không làm dễ ăn cá nhân
Ờ Còn nếu ông làm thích làm chuy nghiệp
ông tách ra từng phần từng phần cũng
được Nhưng mà thường là mình dự ả Mình
đang làm thì kiểu làm đến đâu
Kiểu một là chắc đến đấy hai là cũng chỉ
mình mình làm nên là sửa thì nằm hết
trong một cái prend cũng được mặc định
brend sẽ là main hoặc là Master kiểu như
này đúng không ạ thì mình sẽ đẩy code
lên đây thôi Thì thì đơn giản rồi thường
ông sẽ fake để sẽ kiểm tra xem là có
code mới không có thì ông sẽ p kéo về
đấy Xong rồi bây giờ thì chiến giản đẩy
lên thôi còn cách đẩy thì thường là tôi
sẽ kiểu như
này thường những cái những cái crate này
thì tôi
sẽ Bởi vì bây giờ đang có khá nhiều file
Giả sử Giả sử ông làm Liên quan nhiều
file như này
thường Tại sao có vile này
à sẽ đẩy kiểu như này
đẩy lên trước đã đúng không À Phả gì gì
đó đây là
app telescope chẳng h ạ Đấy tiếp ông em
Bây giờ ngồi nhìn tôi làm gí ông em sẽ
rất là cuu luôn Vì tôi
tôi đa số nhiều người tôi biết thì dùng
lệnh git chứ không kiểu dùng cái github
desktop này nên là thử kiểu có sẽ có hai
trườngng phái đúng không ạ những trường
phải người ta dùng
à Kiểu cái này gọi gì g à đấy để để mà
kiểu dạng là thân thiện giao diện các th
thứ thì sẽ lười kiểu ghi ghi đầy đủ câu
lệnh thì thành ra là người theo trường
phái đấy sẽ khó chịu khi mà mình kiểu
đẩy lên kiểu bằng những cái kiểu mặc
định kiểu như này
đấy tôi theo trường phá kiểu gu Ai sinh
ra có lý do cả nên tôi vẫn dùng nhưng mà
thành ra nó sẽ bị nhiều lúc mà sẽ bị tệ
là kiểu mình Quen dùng cái giao diện rồi
Khi mà mình bảo mình à hiểu rõ về git
này hay là kiểu bảo phải gõ câu lệnh ra
vì g vì cái giao diện này nó sẽ không Hỗ
trợ đầy đủ ấy thì lại chịu đấy đấy nhược
điểm cái
này
trong những cái đôi khi chẳng chẳng sửa
gì cả nhưng mà tôi lỡ Gõ cái À tôi lỡ ấn
cái nút refactor tổng th ra nó kiểu bị
thành ra như này để để đợi cho tí tôi
vào hẳn cái trang này để sửa
admin À
nên thành ra nó bị kiểu đẩy đẩy đẩy như
này thôi đà chấp nhận để để như thế vậy
cứ đẩy hết code Hôm trước đã
nhá Thiếu cái này
sẽ
refactor đúng
config đây sẽ là bên
homepage
đó tiếp là tạo cái
này tạo cái này
này là cũng là
add telescope
test và đây sẽ
là
un
không sử dụng không chưa biết
được remove không đúng comment đi
comment
and play
file Gì
Gì show tun bar cái g gì đó
này cái file này file gì
xem
Kệ Chả ảnh hưởng
Thì ông nên tải về Bởi vì ông kiểu dạng
như à Ông đỡ phải kiểu cần mạng để kết
nối được
còn còn khi mà ông đẩy lên mạng thì ông
hình dung nhá ví dụ là ông đẩy lên
server của ông server ông ở Việt Nam thì
ông kết nối bằng mạng Việt Nam thì về cơ
bản thì nó gần như là nó rất là nhanh
thì thì ông nên để hết code mọi thứ ở
một chỗ ở Nghĩa tại server của ông luôn
còn nếu mà server của ông ở bên nước
ngoài thì khi mà khi mà kiểu truy cập
vào cái trang web của ông là đồng nghĩa
là cũng phải tải hết toàn bộ các file
kiểu js hoặc à JavaScript hoặc là CS từ
nước ngoài về thì thì ví dụ Giả sử đặt ở
bên m Mỹ chẳng hạn đấy thì nghĩa là Tải
mấy cái file đấy hết từ Mỹ về thì ờ thì
tôi thấy là nếu mà để cdn thì nó sẽ kiểu
à Nếu mà để cdn thì cái cái CN tức là
kiểu dạng là một cái file JavaScript hay
là CS kia nó sẽ đặt ở một cái trụ sở
khác thường hay trụ sở đấy nó sẽ có khắp
nơi ở trên thế giới
thì không hẳn là tại từng quốc gia đâu
nhưng mà tại từng khu vực ấy tại mỗi khu
vực gì đó nên là tính ra là lúc đấy dùng
CN nó sẽ nhanh hơn rất là nhiều thế
trong trường hợp mà đấy là lý thuyết Tôi
nhớ mang má Thế nhá Tôi không chắc lắm
nhé Thì thì lúc đấy Khi mà server ông
đặt ở quốc gia khác và nói chung là
người nước ngoài truy cập được ấy thì
ông nên để
mình không chắc
th thc ra thực tế là tôi tôi bảo tôi đi
làm thì tôi làm như nào đ Tôi chỉ biết
chia sẻ lại mấy ông như thế chứ Tôi cũng
không phải là một người quá giành về lý
thuyết để mà thể kiểu để thể khẳng định
một cái gì đó Có vài cái tôi khẳng định
Mạnh mồm được ví dụ Giả sử về SQL tôi
vẫn khẳng định Mạnh mồm được hôm nay tôi
vừa khẳng định Mạnh mồm với sếp tôi xong
sế tôi bảo em Có chắc không em chắc chắn
anh luôn C thử thử thô Sếp tôi vẫn không
tin ạ Buồn lắm nhưng cái đấy tôi chắc
chắc ơ hôm trước mình xóa này rồi
Bảo sao tự nh ôm đấy cứ cảm thấy thừa
thừa mình xá sư đi ạ lỗi tôi lỗi
thật xem
đây có cách
mà đ Xem lịch sử
git
nhanh
dưới content chịu vãi chưởng
thích thì tôi để giống hệt lại cũng được
mình thường để router thì kiểu theo kiểu
dạng slug như này khi mà mình để bên
khách hàng
bị phụ phụ thuộc kiểu cái thằng server
kia đúng không Nếu mà giả sử mà có
server kia có mệnh hệ gì coi như là mình
cũng đi theo Nhưng mà thường thì tùy đấy
mà lẫn cả là mà lẫn cả
là Ờ nếu mà để như thế Hồi trước đã từng
có vụ là kiểu cdn của một cái thư viện
gì đó bị hack ấy là toàn bộ tất cả những
cái bên nào mà dùng cái thư viện đấy
cũng đều đều có thể bị hack đấy n là nó
cũng nó cũng là một bài toán gì gì
đó router tưởng số nhiều á Thực ra là nó
quy ước tùy
thôi Đúng có thể để số nhiều nhưng mà
tôi đang kiểu lười Tôi đặt cho nó kiểu
trùng trùng như này về sao dễ tìm mà Chứ
best practice thì thực ra tôi không nhớ
là best practice là gì cơ hôm trước tôi
khoe với sếp tôi là lal best này này
xong rồi Sếp tôi bảo là ồi Anh chỉ tin
mỗi ông tác giả của larel viết ra thôi
Chứ cái này toàn mấy ông toàn tự sướng
với nhau kiểu nó cũng chỉ một cái Ước gì
đó chứ larel có khuyên thế đâu nó chịu
đy cái đoạn này này dụ Router đúng
không Đấy router để số nhiều này
đấy còn router name thì sẽ là snack cy
với kiểu Dấu chấm này Phân biệt này đấy
đúng không ạ
gọi là về sau mình nói chung à nó là như
nào nó vẫn quay đi quay lại việc là code
sao cho về sau mình dễ mình nhớ được là
Ừ hồi đấy mình đặt là như nào và mình
sửa được đúng không ạ Còn thực sự là ông
đặt tên thích thì ông đặt tên miến a BC
cũng được sao về cho ông dễ sửa ông ông
hình dung ông nhớ được cái A đấy hay cái
gì Cái B Cái đấy hay cái gì còn việc ông
quy ước như thế nào đấy việc của ông và
người làm cùng ông cũng hiểu được cái
đấy ngườ ta vẫn sửa được cái đấy kh ông
thích đặt đặt cái gì cũng được giống như
sếp tôi ấ Bây giờ nhiều người quy là
kiểu comment là phải nên tiếng anh một
tí r kiểu nó nó rõ nghĩa hơn vân vân vân
xế tôi để luôn comment tiếng Việt có dấu
ở trong đấy sa bảo đồng nghiệp Toàn
người Việt với nhau Tại sao phải để thế
nhưng hồi tr như hôm trước thì bị cái
lỗi cũng ngoài ă thật hôm ấy Bọn tôi
phải reverse code xong m ấn vào bên
thằng Pit Pit ấn Open Raw file của nó ra
thì thì toàn bộ cái comment tiếng Việt
của anh đấy Bị kiểu Nó gần như là kiểu
chữ kiểu ch mấy không biết kiểu bị lỗi
ph chữ các thứ thử
không Nghĩa là chữ có dấu nó sẽ bị thành
sai hẳn ấy á á á thì nó kiểu ớ các thứ
thứ đủ loạn loạn hết cả lên đấy nên là
tôi không hẳn là khuyên mấy ông comment
bằng tiếng Việc có dấu tiếng Việt không
dấu cũng được Còn không thì tiếng Anh
thì cũng được Nhưng mà tiếng Anh thì
cũng nên hạn chế đừng thể hiện i chín
chấm ở đấy không ai đọc không ai hiểu
đâu Nói chung là dùng Hãy dùng những
tiếng Anh cơ bản mà ai cũng thể viết
được Nói chung là mấy ông mà lạm dụng
dùng kiểu chbt để viết comment cho ngầu
ấy thì xong rồi về sau không phải ông
tựng nghĩ ra ấy Tức là chỉ là mấy cái từ
đấy có thể thậm chí chính ông C không
biết ấy thì người khác cũng có thể không
biết đâu Thì cái comment đấy nó lại
thành khiến nhau mệt hêm đúng không
à Nãy giờ cứ mải nói gì cũng chưa làm
được cái gì cả đợi tí đợi tí bây giờ
mình sẽ quay lại bên hom page để sửa lại
nhá
Ờ thì hôm trước là sửa hôm trước sửa cái
bên này này một cái này hai cái này đúng
không ạ đại loại này mề mề cái kiểu như
này
mấy ông cái kiểu dạng là
lý hơn
mình sẽ có
cái mình ông Để ý kỹ là là hôm trước thì
làm một cái là save này à store này tức
là thêm mới này một cái là update
này đấy
à Cả hai đều là để kiểu nói chung gộp
chung là cập nhật thông tin ở trong DB
đúng không ạ để mà bên cái giao diện f
này mình sẽ hiển thị ra đúng chưa Nhưng
mà thường là admin khi mà cập nhật mấy
cái này cái này đang còn gọi là config
mà tức là nó sẽ ít thay đổi đúng không ạ
Nó sẽ rất ít hãy đổi thường là để cái
này vài tháng thậm chí là để lâu hơn thì
rõ ràng là cái này cứ mỗi lần Tải hại
trang lại truy vấn lại như này truy vấn
rất nhiều và trong confix các thứ thứ
như này th ra không ổn là ông em làm
kiểu này nó không ổn lắm này Đấy th giờ
thì nên làm như thế nào thì mình sẽ bây
giờ mình sẽ dùng cách mình sẽ kích lại
kch lại dữ liệu đây đầu tiên tôi sẽ cho
mấy ông
xem đầu tiên mình làm cách trữ lại nhá
nằm ở trong homepage controller này
client
content Thực ra bây giờ không còn inmate
nữa thì
phải đúng không nhỉ
ơ vẫn còn New rival inmate á Đợi tôi một
tí hình như vừa tôi thêm lại cái đoạn
đấy nó cũng sai tại sao mình cần newel
inmate nhỉ Chỉ cần content th
nhỉ Mình có load cái thằng new inmate
đâu đây content đy nhá tôi Xóa các phần
đăng ảnh rồi mà
nhỉ à Thôi tôi nhớ lý do rồi đăng ảnh
cái
được
thế lô mà chạy
không
rồi
mất rồi À
đó đổi lại thành cái
th chỗ này lại giữ nguyên này Chỗ này
giữ nguyên
này thôi Tôi nghĩ là tôi dùng thống nhất
đi Tôi bảo rồi đôi khi là mình này phải
dùng thống nhất cho nó chung chứ chỗ này
một kiểu chỗ kia một kiểu không
cái activity
nào có gì chiếm nhiều ấy nhỉ Ui Cái này
chiếm tận 40 ph Ừ tôi đang nghĩ là
à Tôi đang nghĩ
là chắc là sang năm tôi sẽ phải mua con
max Bây giờ tôi đang dùng Macbook
E1 của công ty cấp chắc là sang năm tôi
có thể đổi lên tôi định lúc đầu tôi sẽ
định đổi lên là Macbook
định thế
thôi đy Kiểu như này submit đó update
successed thì ở đây sẽ là thêm một cái
xin không sự kiện ngày mai đấy
đấy thì Ờ bây giờ mấy ông Nói chung là
cái vụ new inmate cái này thực ra không
cần nữa này c xóa đi xem có lỗ gì không
nhá tại mình phải nên viết test đạn này
tự nhiên có lỗi buồn cười
à hại chang này
lỗi chàng lấu thế
Ờ chắc là lỗi
nhớ như có cả test vụ view tôi chưa viết
test vụ view bởi vì trên công ty tôi
dùng làm tôi làm thuần bằng api f thì sẽ
ph qu ra Script chứ tôi không test vụ
view nên cũng không biết không chắc là
larel hình như có hỗ trợ test vụ view
đấy đấy không lỗi gì này chứng tỏ là
kiểu đấy bớt đi một câu truy vấn nhưng
mà về cơ bản thì tôi vẫn muốn là cái này
tôi không tru vấn nữa mà tôi sẽ lấy ra
nhắn anh xem cần chữa gì nhỉ Em nhắn
chưa ở phần trạng thái đơn
đơn nhưng nó vẫn hi hiển thị phòng đã
trong cái này thì anh nghĩ là em thử
export cho anh cái A databas của em xong
anh thử import vào rồi anh truy vấn Hẳng
để anh sửa cho thì nó sẽ dễ hơn em có D
database rồi đúng
database xong anh thử sửa cho thì cái
đoạn này thì
Bây giờ tôi định làm thì tôi sẽ kiểu
thường sẽ có hai cách làm
Ờ
thôi mà thôi tôi chắc chỉ nói qua một
cách thôi sẽ làm như
này tôi thường này viết kiểu nh
này get
and by key như này t chuyển key vào như
này x tôi sẽ Return về tôi gọi cách kiểu
này
remember này s ngồi đây là key luôn
ty tôi thường hay làm theo kiểu như này
tôi sẽ dùng một cái tạo một cái i5 là
cách key kiểu như này để về sau mình sẽ
biết được là Ừ thì thì mình có cái cái
dự án mình có những cái key nào đang
cách và về sau mình sẽ hỗ trợ xóa th
cách key các thử
thứ đây
để và mình nên có một cái kiểu dạng một
cái kiểu i5 quy ước gì đó chứ không mấy
cái chuỗi mình đừng có nên hot code kiểu
này thường mình nên có một cái quy ước
gì đó đặt ở đâu đó thì người sau người
ta sẽ làm theo quy ước đấy chứ mỗi chứ
đoạn chỗi kiểu này mỗi chỗ ông đặt một
kiểu nó sẽ không được Nó không nên
này À nãy còn chưa mở cái mở bàn phím
lên cho mấy
đấy th sẽ sang p
i5 K
pp8 thì nó có i5 rồi nhưng mà tôi vẫn
cảm thấy là dùng cái thư viện i5 này nó
vẫn có cái gì đó hơn nên tôi vẫn dùng
cái này
public constant đy config Chuẩn rồi
gian là 60 x 60 thường mình chả cần phải
nhớ cái này thường
là mình
nên thường công ty tôi quy ước cái vụ
này luôn ở trong cá key này đó
là
m à
5 m nghe không
đầu đúng không
thôi mình cũng một tiếng mà
nó sẽ
là
one out chẳng
nhân 60 phút Ừ đúng
kiểu tầm kiểu một tháng thôi nhá Tôi vẫn
nhớ là kiểu người đi trước của tôi đã để
lại quả cách không phải cách Thứ nhất là
tôi từng nói mấy ông Ừ kiểu gạch dưới
kiểu kiau cũng được nhưng mà thôi Ờ
ờ người đi trước từc để quả đoạn thứ
nhất là tôi từng nói mấy ông về cái vụ
là đừng bao giờ dùng cách forever bởi vì
về sau mình quên không xóa cách rồi đi
cách cái sẽ lưu mãi nó sẽ bị nặng kiểu
dạng là cách này bản chất là nó lưu lại
ở trong trong đâu ấy nhỉ nhớ Hình như là
một chỗ nà Đó cái đ này còn đôi khi còn
phụ thuộc vào ông Chỉnh trong nv của ông
ông lưu kch dạng gì sử dạng file như này
hoặc là dạng Credit hoặc là database tùy
như đại khái
là nó đã tốn bộ nhớ các thứ thứ nế là
không bao giờ để forever căng nhất thì
tầm để một tháng như này thôi nhớ người
đi trước tôi để lại quả cách cách tận 1
năm ạ kch 1 năm thì đừng có kch không ai
điên kích tận 1 năm ạ V Chiểu kiểu
Ờ sao cái đoạn đấy còn chẳng bao giờ sửa
ấy đừng nhá Đừng V Kích 1 năm thật
đấy hô mày Tôi nhìn kiểu ánh mắt kểu khó
hiểu
Nếu mà CH Giả sử ông chỉ muốn lấy mỗi
cột valu ra cái này tiện ích của tôi là
nó nó sẽ cũng hay phết khi mà tôi kiểu
dùng chuột hay vì bấm phím tắt nó sẽ
cảnh báo lên một cái để chỉ mày dùng
phím tắt đi nó sẽ nhanh hơn hơn đấy
lấy value như này thì thực ra mình chỉ
cần value như này được gửi tôi nghĩ Tạm
thời như này thì bây giờ mình sẽ thay
vào đây thôi Cái này tôi sẽ để nó là
static
nh để là mình có thể gọi được Kiểu như
này
này Đây đang có bảy câu truy vấn tại
trang Thực ra nó vẫn là B bởi vì mình
phải ít nhất là truy vấn một lần đã rồi
mình kck vào đúng không
lỗi on
string sao chả về lỗi được nhỉ
À đúng rồi bây giờ mình trả về thẳng
value Thực ra trả thằng về value thì in
ra mỗi value thôi mình tự nhiên mình trả
thêm cả key và các thứ thứ khối trước là
thực ra thành
thừa bên
client
copy copy bên này cho nhanh view
tru vấn và không biết ở đây có kh có nói
việc mình dùng cách không hình như không
trong này thiếu mất cái vụ là mình có
dùng cách hay không Ừ nhưng mà trong a
van chạ telescope thì có nhá telescope
Nó sẽ kiểu nói rõ là mấy ông có dung kch
hay không thì rất là
hay
à đâu
này đây cách này có cách hit tức là hám
chỉ là nó Nó
kiểu hit dịch ra ở đây
không phải đấm nhá không phải đánh mà nó
kiểu kiểu đã sử dụng nó bình thường ông
sẽ có khái niệm là hit này Miss này với
gì nhở nhớ là có một cái nữa là là kiểu
ông đâu Tôi thử nếu ông muốn xóa cách
thì để xóa toàn bộ cách thì ông thể dùng
cái hàm này thực ra ông đừng có chạy cái
này trên production
nhá công ty ông đang có dung cách mà tự
nhiên chạy cái này tr bo xoái cách đi
chết luôn hệ thống đấy bởi vì hệ thống
đấy đang quen dùng cách của tự nhiên
kiểu một loạt kiểu truy vấn và dp chết
luôn quá tả
chết hồi trước công ty tôi cũng bị một
phát mà không phải ừ cũng có thể bị chạy
kiểu xóa kch kiểu thế nhưng mà một cái
thứ hai đó là lỡ chuyển server sang chỗ
khác mất kch chết luôn thệ th đây một
cái mid À đúng rồi một cái nữa set đấy
Lúc đầu sẽ kiểu Nếu mà giả sử mà không
mà chưa lấy được thì sẽ xét lại nhưng mà
xét cái này hình như là tôi nhớ có một
cái fail chẳng ạn thì như thế là xét
nhưng không xét được đó đây là một cái
nhưng mà Đây mới chỉ dừng ở cơ bản tôi
dạy cho mấy ông khái niệm nâng cao hơn
một tí mấy ông sẽ cảm thấy Ui ngầu vãi
chưa Nó sẽ là như nàoo nhất là nó sẽ trả
về C ở đây Chắc chắn rồi à Đâu xing chứ
Ở đây chả về mỗi value mà mỗi value thì
nó sẽ là kiểu trả về dữ liệu là
stream thì mấy ông thấy Ok anh vừa dạy
em về cách em rất thích đúng không ạ
Nhưng nếu Giả sử kiểu bài toán thực tế
thì cái value này Thực ra bây giờ đang
chỉ string thì tương đối nhẹ bây giờ giả
sử nhá Giả sử nhá Tôi muốn cách Tôi muốn
cách cái thằng config này tôi muốn trả
về cả một cái object config này thì rõ
ràng tôi sẽ đổi đây là s như này thì trả
về toàn bộ cả config đúng không Tôi cứ
tôi Return hẳn thằng anh nhá tôi làm tôi
cứ làm trên này demo cho mấy ông Return
thẳ hàng anh nhá Để mấy ông xem qua nhá
và bây giờ tôi cứ clear cách để cho mấy
ông dễ hình dung
tôi chậm chư phải do code chậm
Return ở đây là Return về kiểu dạng là
là Ờ làm cái kiểu nó biến thành jion rồi
nên thành ra mấy ông không xem được m
xem lại kiểu này nhé t tắt C đi này
đấy nó sẽ trả về cho ông một cái đối
tượng này đúng không thực tế thực tế đó
là không biết là công ty ông có vận dụng
kiểu sử dụng mấy cái kiểu các thứ các
thứ kiểu của một Hằng mồ hay không nhưng
nhưng khi mà
tôi tôi và ở công ty tôi dùng cách
ấy thì tôi muốn là chỉ cách dữ liệu của
cái thằng MU đồ này thôi chứ tôi không
khi mà tôi cách này tôi không hề muốn
dùng lại những cái tôi không muốn dùng
tôi không quan tâm việc dùng lại những
cái kiểu dạng là những cái attribute hay
là creation trừ khi n m l dùng creation
thì mình sẽ phải Quick creation ra chứ
mình không không kiểu chọ thẳng kiểu lấy
lấy thêm reation nữa Tôi không dùng thêm
bất kỳ cái thuộc tính gì của thằng mod
thì tính là tôi không nên kch cả mod đồ
vì cách mồ này nó cũng rất nặng m không
hiểu ý tôi không ạ tôi nói về bài toán
tối ưu nhá Tôi đang dạy mấy ông về tư
cách là senio chứ không còn là j nên tôi
sẽ dạy nó cũng khá là nâng cao khá nhiều
đấy nó bài toán thực tế hơn ấy thì thì
mấy ông thấy là tôi đang cách cả cái
thằng này nó sẽ rất là nặng thế bây giờ
làm nào để sửa lại đoạn này thì thường
là tôi sẽ làm như này thường mình
sẽ mình sẽ thường ha làm
là thế cách cái nào bây giờ nhẹ thì mình
chỉn giảng là mình cách
mỗi mình cách mỗi kiểu dạng là đối tượng
này
thôi Tôi thường n Gọi to như này nhưng
với điều kiện Chắc chắn là thằng này nó
phải trả về giá trị nhá Không tu này báo
lỗ đấy nhá Được không ạ thêm hỏi chấm
như này nó không lỗi đây là cái pp8 nó
hỗ trợ điều này pp7 nó sẽ không điểu này
đấy Và nếu trong trường hợp mà nó không
tìm thấy thì cũng nên trả về cái này là
nun này đúng không ạ Đây thì nó sẽ trả
về như
này à quên tôi đang kch nhỉ tạm xóa toạn
luôn Xóa kch
Sale nữa mà bây giờ nó sẽ trả về cái gì
này tạ xóa lạ điể mấy ông dễ hình dung
hơn này sẽ trả về cho mình một cái zon
là một cái đoạn
chuỗi chứa toàn bộ dữ liệu của thằng này
Nhưng mà theo dạng chuỗi zion
đấy không biết th này có T object không
nhở sao
object không nó không có to object đấy
thế bây giờ Làm thế nào để biến thằng
này về cơ bản mình vẫn muốn thao tác nó
như với một cái thằng object Thì bây giờ
mình sẽ mình cách lại thì cách Hằng ng
Nhưng mình sẽ bản chất là sẽ Tôi thường
khai báo đây là là ờ string như này
chẳng hạn Hoặc là ông khai báo z đi
code nó ra để nó biến nó thành đối tượng
thường nó sẽ bảo thêm một vài cái lỗi
lỗi này nữa như thường tôi cũng không
Tôi không biết cái đp này như nào rồi
cái disable cái này
object tôi sẽ làm việc với cái thằng
object
đ thay vì thay vì
tôi đây thứ nhất là mấy ông vừa hình
dung được là tôi thay vì vừa cách lại cả
một thằng mod nó sẽ rất là lớn Hồi trước
công ty tôi bị thế bởi công ty tôi dùng
cách rất là nhiều dự án lớn rồi mà bây
giờ chục triệu người dùng rồi thì nó sẽ
khác chục không phải người dùng mà chục
triệu khách hàng Ờ thì thì lượng truy
cập rất là lớn nên là mình sẽ cách rất
nhiều thứ mà việc cách cả thằng MU đồ
cách cách thế nhiều Hồi trước bị cũng bị
Kiểu cái hệ thống kch cũng bị kiểu bị
nặng ấy bở lưu rất nhiều thứ đấy nên là
phải chuyển qua là sẽ kiểu lưu lại chuỗi
như này lưu lại chuỗi Rất là nhẹ mà đúng
không Đấy sau đó thì khi mà lấy ra khỏi
cách thì mình sẽ kiểu biến nó lại thành
đối đối tượng để mình xử lý nó như đối
tượng Bình thường thôi Cái này đương
nhiên là như tôi vừa nói nó sẽ không nó
sẽ không còn giữ được những cái thuộc
tính những attribute những cái kiểu tính
năng của thằng mod nữa Nên là nếu ông
muốn làm gì với nó thì ông phải làm ngay
trong này ví dụ Giả sử ông sẽ ông muốn
thêm cái creation nào đó thì ông sẽ phải
qut ở trong này quit một cái gì gì đó để
mà mình sẽ lưu lại cái đấy kèm với jion
đấy còn không thì coi như là ông ông
thao tác bình thường thôi và cái thứ hai
nữa đó là mod của thằng larel nó có hỗ
trợ là ông làm theo
kiểu đối xử kiểu dùng từ đối xử không
đang dùng hết tiếng Việt n thà từ đối xử
nó hơi thô nhỉ Nhưng mà ông xử lý nó như
một như một object hoặc như một array
được ông biết vụ đấy không ạ Thằng m
riêng Thằng m Đồ thằng larel nó cho kiểu
ông có thể một là ông dùng kiểu dạng như
này cũng được ho ông ghi kiểu như này
cũng được nghĩa là kiểu xử lý nó với tư
cách aray object đều được còn nếu mà ông
làm ch kiểu như này rồi thì đ thì ông
bắt buộc phải xử lý nó như một kiểu
object hoặc làm kiểu như này thì ông xử
lý nó như kiểu array đúng không tôi vẫn
thường th thích object hơn thích kiểu
dạng kiểu con trò kiểu kia hơn là kiểu
dùng ngọc vuông nên tôi sẽ thích kiểu
như
này mấy ông nghe đến đoạn này có à Chắc
chắn là nửa số trong đống này tôi khẳng
định nửa số trong đúng này Không làm
theo cách của công ty tôi hiện tại nên
là có thể khó hiểu Và thậm chí là chưa
động đên bao giờ nhưng mà ông nào ở đây
hiểu không ạ hiểu Nãy giờ tôi nói gì
không ạ
đó để lại một cái dấu chấm một tia thần
pp stor cái này cách này chỉ dùng được
larel hay sao hay dùng fw work khác được
không cách này thì đối với larel thì nó
mới kiểu có kiểu MU đồ như này còn nhưng
mà đây là một cái gợi ý cho em là kiểu
dạng là là mình cách thì mình nên cách
cái gì đó nhẹ xong rồi mình xử mình lấy
ra mình xử lý đừng có cách của cái gì nó
nặng quá nó chết hệ thống cách có vấn đề
đúng
hiểu đúng không hiểu hiểu thì bây giờ
sang cái mới khó hơn nhá OK thì mấy ông
vừa thấy là cái này nó dừng lại ở việc
lấy à Nó vẫn chỉ nó vẫn chỉ là lấy từ
trong cách ra Thế bây giờ mình có một
bài toán nữa đó là tôi thấy lấy từ trong
cách ra nó vẫn lâu thì bây giờ mình làm
như nho tôi tôi Thực ra tôi cũng không
dành về cái vụ local static đâu nhá bây
giờ hỏi để tôi thử xem
cách mấy ông biết Khải niệm cách satic
niệm cách
static cái này kích vào trong biến
luôn và mà đương nhiên là mình hoàn toàn
có thể sử dụng lại được cái biến này ở
rất nhiều chỗ khác Và thậm chí là khi mà
pp Tắt rồi nó vẫn nghĩa là chỉ là code
chạy Xong rồi nghĩa là ví dụ Ông cứ Hình
dung là bình thường code pp là kiểu khi
mà code xong khi mà xử lý xong hết rồi
đúng không Thì dữ liệu toàn bộ dữ liệu
nó sẽ kiểu bị xóa sạch các thứ thì em
chỉ là khi mà ông gọi lại nó thì ông
không tận dụng lại cái biến cũ được đúng
không đấy còn satic này trường hợp khác
nghĩa là nó vẫn sẽ vẫn Lư lại ở trong
code của ông không phải trong code như
đại khai nó vẫn lưu lại trong bộ nhớ chứ
nó không xóa đi thế nên là mình nghĩa là
sao Tức là ví dụ đơn giản nhá Tôi khai
báo một biển a bằ 5 đúng không Tôi chạy
Xong cos rồi thường cái biến a đấy nó sẽ
kểu bị bị kiểu nó sẽ bị xóa đi khỏi bộ
nhớ đúng
không và đặc biệt là người khác truy cập
vào nữa thà ra mà kiểu Gọi gọi ra cái
biến a đấy nó sẽ có thể không tồn tại
đúng không Bởi vì nó chưa từng khai báo
nhưng còn satic này tức là ông khai báo
rồi ông sẽ dùng lại được ở không những
là ông dùng lại được mà người khác truy
cập vào cái phần mềm Ông vẫn có thể dùng
lại được đấy đây local request l
ở chỗ khác à Chỉ trong mỗi live ccle
thôi à Ồ tôi lại tưởng người khác có thể
dùng được để xem mà đúng nhỉ dịch cái
này đúng nhỉ
À
này của tôi
À ừ nế thế p nó vẫn là hạn chế của pp
Nghĩa Chị ở kiểu nhiều người request thì
nó vẫn load lại không dùng chung
được Nhưng không sao Mình vẫn mình có
hai tầng cách mà mình một tầng là cách
bằng redit này rồi một tầng cách là
cách đây mình dùng redit Mà tôi sẽ dùng
redit
7 của em đây ạ Ok Đợi anh tí anh Chữa
nốt cái này nhá Ờ thì tôi hướng Tôi sẽ
chỉ cho ông cái về khai báo sa tích là
như nào thì tôi sẽ thường tôi sẽ có một
cái ở đây t đặt tên là
Private
array
cách như này và bằng
rỗng ở đây tôi sẽ có một cái là Vision
xử lý thử thử này đúng không th sẽ ở đây
là
à data
à data đi bằng như này sau đó thì mình
sẽ cách nó
này à Không cái này không còn là zit nữa
Đợi tí Đợi
À đây satic quên
mất Thiếu cái
và ở đây tôi sẽ là kiểm tra nếu mà có
như này tôi Return thẳng luôn đây đây là
hoàn chỉnh cái Cách Cách ở trên công ty
tôi đang làm như này tức là sao mấy ông
sẽ thấy là tôi sẽ tạo ra một cái biến là
cách kiểu này và dạng static và nó là
mảng tại sao nó lại mảng Bởi vì nếu mà
từng từng gọi đến cái cách này rồi từng
truyền đúng cái key này rồi thì tôi trả
về luôn tôi không Tôi không gọi đến qua
cách của redit nữa mà đây là cách của
biến Tôi sẽ trả về thẳng luôn Như như
này sau đó nếu mà giả sử không có đúng
không ạ thì tôi mới sử dụng cách của
biến như này để tôi xong rồi tôi lưu lại
trong cách biến như này là trả về cái
này tức là sao ví dụ Giả sử Giả sử nhá
Tôi gọi ở đây rất nhiều lần như
này
tôi tôi sử dụng theo cách tôi xá tạm
đoạn này đi nhá xá tạm đng My đi
tôi chạy x m không hình dung
ã tôi
đây Return về một cái
new
này về để nói chung là cần cái Return để
cho thằng telescope này nhận được đấy
Ông thấy là sử dụng sáu lần cách một lần
set những lần còn lại kiểu sử dụng tận
dụng l cái kch cũ tận dụng kch cũ đúng
chứ nghĩa nó sẽ gọi vào redit để để lấy
lại K đúng không Đấy Bây giờ tôi mở lại
cái đoạn này lên
chạy
đây ông thấy một lần mid một lần set
không thể gọi vào bên redit nữa đấy thấy
xịn hơn không xị n rất nhiều luôn đây là
trong trường hợp mà
cái ông đương nhiên bài toán sẽ có thể
là nhề lúc ông ông sẽ bảo cái này th các
em chỉ cần lấy ra kích một lần thôi Kiểu
đ trong một request của em em chỉ sử
dụng cái này một lần em
không Em không kiểu dạng là không sử
dụng lại cái dữ liệu này nhiều lần nên
thành ra em không cần phải không cần
phải
kiểu cách cách x tích kiểu này Ừ cũng
đúng nhưng mà ở công ty tôi thì không
công ty tôi cái cái liên quan đến config
này này được sử dụng lại rất nhiều lần
nên trong một request luôn ấy nên là nên
là bài toán là nếu nếu có thể thì mình
vẫn nên cách lại đúng không cách sích
này thì các bạn cũng chẳng tốn gì cả mấy
nó tính ra nó vẫn chỉ tốn dung lượng bộ
nhớm một tí thôi Bởi vì tính này cái này
sẽ lấy từ trong RAM Còn cái này lấy từ
trong Credit r nó về C bạn nhanh hơn thì
vậy nhớ là thế
nhớ là thế thôi còn ông nào ông nào mà
thấy tôi nói gì sai cứ bảo tôi sửa cho
tôi sửa sớm cho đỡ ngựa Ờ nhưng mấy ông
vừa thấy qua mấy ông hiểu cái tôi vừa
nói qua về vụ cách nà không m Ông thấy
xịn hơn không xịn hơn đúng
không gần như là khai báo một cái biến
bình thường để ông lưu lại nó ông lấy từ
trong cái biến đấy thay vì Lấy thẳng
trực tiếp từ redit thôi mà đúng không
thực tế tôi mới biết vụ này trên trường
Chắc chắn là không không ai dạy mấy ông
về vụ này cả cùng lắm là chỉ dạy ông lý
thuyết sa tích là cái gì đúng
phản đối gì cả thì cứ coi như là mấy ông
đều cứ hình dung qua rồi nhá Còn nếu tôi
nghĩ về sau kiểu gì với ông sẽ tiếp xúc
v cái bài toán
này cái biến nó khi nào chết anh nhỉ thì
tôi vừa hỏi chat vity cho mấy ông ấy tôi
cũng mới biết lại đây đó là là cái thằng
p thì về cơ bản thì khi kết thúc một cái
kiểu Cái live Circle của nó tức cả khi
mà xử lý xong ấy thì nó cũng xóa xóa cái
dữ liệu của biến đi thôi nghĩa biến
satic này cũng sẽ biến mất đây chỉ phạm
vi hoạt động trong một request duy nhất
và và trong chu kỳ sống l cle của Script
pp đó đy không duy trì qua yêu cầu khác
nhau không dùng chung qua nhiều người
dùng được đấy còn nếu dùng chung qua hay
các thứ thứ thì nên dùng cách bình
thường nhưng mà tôi bảo rồi Cái này phù
hợp cho việc là phù hợp cho việc là kiểu
trong một request của ông gọi lại cái
này nhiều thì ông nên ông nên sử dụng
theo cách
này gọi là biết thôi đúng không
ạ
đấy thấy Dự thấy kiểu kinh nghiệm thực
tế nó khác với cái lý thuyết hồi trước
dạy không Trước dạy chắc là mấy ông chỉ
biết mỗi
Ờ mấy ông chỉ biết mỗi cách remember
thậm chí remember
forever kiểu như À quên mất còn vụ xóa
kch nữa vụ xóa kch nữa cơ nhưng mà tôi
nghĩ là để tôi chữa cho ông này trước đã
nhé tôi chữa ông này trước
đã
virus gì không nhỉ tt tr Sậu
quá Chắc không sao đâu nó thế mấy ông
đừng có gửi virus tôi nhá đặt phòng
này
database
ph
nhỉ
export t tu ở
nhà à
đây ddl
file thử
file bạn kia lại gửi cho file
txt file này hình như là file ddl mà
đúng
tí đ
rồi không biết thằng này có cái vụ là
kiểu import vào không nhớ trước là có
nhớ là có
đấy
sao
stone
import
ddl
plugin databas tool ồ cái plugin
mà lừa nhỉ Xong rồi sao Now
chết cái gì đấy Ông này dùng Collection
gì đấy ông dị
dùng gì nh General ho là hoặc là Unicode
ông dùng gener Tại sao dùng cái
luôn tì thế đúng
không dùng cái mấy 9000
À đây đoạn này không dùng version này à
đâ
À cái này là gì
đó
Translate rõ ràng C Xem T Ồ c x hồ trước
mình không phân biệt hoa thường Ồ xịn xị
ái Xong rồi làm tôi in không
không có lỗi lỗi do máy
tôi đợi tí đợi tí sửa lại được
xá này đi cũng chạy mà đúng không
đ Xong rồi ch không lỗi gì đâu quan tâm
gì mình cái đấy Ở
một cách mà đúng
m Ông đừng thử chá đấy ở công ty
ph
sao thế
Ông ông lại lừa rô rồi xem ạ
gắn phòng
auto để con số này
phòng để em lọc lại Ạ thẽ chứng tỏ không
Đúng Đúng không ông lại lừa tôi
rồi thôi à thực ra vẫn phải có sự chặt
chẽ dữ liệu thì câu tr vầ nó mới đúng
nha thô ông ông sửa lại ông gửi lại tôi
chung thôi đó là mấy ông trước khi gửi
file cho ai đó đặc biệt là liên quan đến
kiểu tôi Tôi không nói cá nhân tôi tôi
thực ra thoải mái thôi Nhưng mà chắc
chắn người khác kiểu đặc biệt ở công ty
đặc biệt kiểu giống như v cái đầu buổi
tôi tâm sự Tôi nói ông cái tâm sự về
đồng nghệp Tôi nhắn tôi ấ
thì mình làm sao cho mà họ cảm thấy là
kiểu thoải mái và gọi là mình cấu Tiến
hay cái gì gì đó để mà họ hoàn toàn
thoải mái hỗ trợ mình ấy Ví dụ là kiểu
trước khi gửi cho họ trước khi gửi email
cho hay là bất kỳ cái gì cho một ai đó
mình luôn kiểm tra kỹ lại các thứ thứ để
để phòng kiểu bởi vì có nhiều người khó
tính người ra kiểu đặc biệt là có thể
tôi tôi thì dễ tính nhưng mà lúc mà tôi
đang tự nhiên tôi đang khó chịu đang
đang xử lý BC của tôi đúng không Tự
nhiên ai đó mà nhờ tôi kiể fb hộ xong
rồi người ra kiểu dạng là gửi cho mình
kiểu hơi hợt ấy có thể mình sẽ không hỗ
trợ đâu đúng không Đấy Nói chung là
mình mình gọi là mang tiếng đi nhờ vả
Đúng không Thì mình không phải không nhờ
được thì vải nhá mà là mình cũng phải
kiểu Hồi trước tôi có cái ảnh ở trên
Facebook tôi để đó là nếu mà bạn muốn
được câu trả lời có tâm ấy thì bạn phải
đặt câu hỏi có tâm đấy Có tâm ở đây
nghĩa là bạn phải cũng phải tâm huyết
cho cái câu hỏi đấy không hỏi một cách
hời hợt được có rất nhiều người Hồi
trước hỏi tôi kiểu một cách hời hợt làm
tôi nhưng mà tôi vì tôi dễ tí quá nên
thành ra tôi cũng cũng nhắn lại họ kiểu
tôi phải hỏi kỹ lại xem họ thực sự hỏi
gì ý Sao tôi kiểu phải hỏi ba bốn lần
cần cái gì ý đấy họ nhắn tin trả lời trả
lời mình m Thế là giống như kiểu mình
phải xin
họ xin họ là kiểu mày để tao giúp đi ấ
kiểu kểu thế đấy Nói chung là thực ra là
bởi vì tính mình khác nhưng mà nhưng mà
Mấy ông cũng phải cải thiện cái đấy
phảiì Không thì mấy ông tôi bảo rồi tôi
ở trên công ty Tôi không phải là con nhà
người ta tôi vẫn kém rất nhiều Tôi đi
nhờ và Ôi Sếp tôi rất nhiều lúc Sếp tôi
bây giờ không khác gì cái thầy đầu tiên
Ờ của tôi cả ngồi cạnh tôi lúc nào cũng
bị tôi thình thả quay ra hỏi thì giả tôi
quay ra nói nói Sếp tôi cao cực nhưng mà
sếp tôi cũng bảo tôi là thú vui gọi là
thú vui tiêu khiển của anh ơi nghe chỉ
kiểu ông ông bây giờ ông cứ hình dung
ông đi làm một thằng ngồi cạnh Hơi tí là
hỏi mà trong khi đó
là sẽ bị sao nhãng là một thứ hai là
mình giúp nó mình có được cái gì đâu đấy
các thứ thử đấy nhưng mà tôi tôi bằng
cách thần thánh ởo đó tôi làm cho sếp
tôi cảm thấy kiểu
kiểu những cái hôm mà tôi kiểu phải nghỉ
kiểu có lý do các thử thử ý xếp tội đồng
nghiệp khác Toàn bảo
nm Long hôm nay không đi làm kểu anh
Bình trầm cảm vãi trưởng Anh Bình cả
ngày không nói cái gì cả anh Bình anh
Bình chẳng cả ngày không cười cái gì cả
đấy các thứ thứ còn nay Long đi làm thấy
anh anh Bình lại ngồi cười cả buổi có
nhiều vãi trưởng kểu thế nghĩa là ông
vừa tạo được không khí các thứ thứ mang
tiếng ở nhề vả Đúng không Nói chung phải
Tôi nghĩ
là không không phải là việc ông không
nên nên hỏi phải học hỏi liên tục nhưng
mà ông phải học cách hỏi đúng không cái
đấy quan
trọng anh dùng m gì đấy ạ Tôi dùng m M1
em1 công ty cấp nên thực ra có gì dùng
lấy nhưng mà tính ra nó vẫn khá là mượt
rất là ổn không vấn đề gì cả Bởi vì công
ty th ra vẫn quan tâm về hiệu năng của
anh em nên là nên là kiểu công ty cũng
sắm cho anh em các thứ cũng gọi là
ổn ở ở công ty tôi công ty Còn sắm cho
cái con dog tức là kiểu bình thường M1
này sẽ chỉ xuất ra được một màn hình ấy
nhưng
mà nhưng mà kiểu công ty cấp dog nó có
thể nổi xuất ra được tận hai màn hình
này đấy tiện m chưởng tối ưu thêm về các
thứ em cứ mặt vui lên mật buồn thế Anh
buôn theo thật đấy cứ tới tỉnh l thoải
mái có sao đâu
dòng mà Easy
không
nhỉ ch set Lion hả có cái này đy nhỉ Ơ
bấm nhầm bấm nhầm bấm nhầm sao có cái
này đấy
không phải file này
này tôi thử xem qua phòng
nhá đầu tiên là phòng
này Thực ra tự nhiên tôi nhìn cái này
tôi lại muốn sang bên đ
không
code cho bạn đấy rồi tôi nhớ là hôm
trước tôi vừa code bạn đấy ở đây
này
phòng
đế Mình chỉ cần test một vài phòng thôi
Ờ có tám phòng đúng không ạ đặt
phòng đặt
phòng có gắn phòng nữa đúng không gắn
phòng ID đặt phòng
nhảy mình bỏ những cái cột không cần đi
Ờ mình quan tâm
id id đặt phóng nối sang bây giờ đầu
tiên thì như hôm trước bảo thì mình cần
truy vấn ra cái những phòng đang đặt đã
đầu tiên mình chạy thử cái này đã mình
mình cứ chạy thử cái này trước đã đúng
không đấy ai đây
là sửa lại tí nào đầu tiên là đây là
đắt phòng này rồi với gắn phòng này xịn
không xịn nhìn chuẩn bị của tôi gợi ý đó
Xịn không quá xịn nhưng mà do ông đặt
không thể gợi ý
đặt phòng
chấm lấy ra những phòng đang được đặn
nhá thì phải là
này sẽ lấy cho tất cả những cái phòng đã
đã đặt từ trước nay đúng chứ đúng không
đ
dung mà đúng
là
đi Phòng chấm sao tôi cũng chưa biết
được hết toàn bộ thông tin
của mọi thứ Nên tôi sẽ cứ chấm Sao đi
ngày check in ngày check out này đúng
không Mình sẽ que Giả sử là ngày check
in
này mình mình muốn lấy trong cái khoảng
thời gian kiểu Dạ như này để biết được
không Comment lại à đâu chẳng cần
comment đâu sửa lại luôn đây được
mà Ngày check in này
check out
nó hơi xấu thông cảm nhé
thể set một cái ở trên này như này set
một cái time start như này time end như
này chẳng hạn đ sẽ
là time
start
time
này Cái này đặt tên biến của của SQL đấy
tiếp theo là
ờ trạng thái đơn đúng không trạng thái
đơn bằng 1 đúng không bằng 1 tức là trạ
thái đơn này là gì em nhỉ một là gì hai
là
Ngà check out này ĐT phòng chạng thái
đơn này để mình thử select nó trước khi
có cái đoạn này
ờ
rồi lấy đây Ok
khoảng thời gian đã đặt đúng không
Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
lấy kiểm tra Ví dụ ở trong khoảng thời
gian đây à mùng 1 đến mùng 3 chẳng hạn 1
đến
03 đúng không Thì sẽ ra được phải ra
được là đây phòng phòng 3 phòng 2 đều bị
đặt rồi đúng không Đúng không nhỉ Ừ Hình
như sai sai
đấy
đợi đợi tôi
tí Đợi tôi một
đúng cái trạng thái đơn bạn này hai đây
sẽ
là tháng 2 này mùng 1 đến tận ngày
ngày 13
có phải là sẽ chung ở cái lịch này đúng
đó mùng 1 đến ngày mùng 3 Ok đó ra hai
hai cái chuẩn
hai là gì nhưng là đây cứ tạm quan tâm
vế việc đã đặt đã đúng không đấy thì đây
có phải là ra được tất cả phòng đã được
đặt trong khoảng thời gian đấy Thì bây
giờ mình chỉ đơn giản là select
sao
form form phòng đúng không
que một là id not in trong cái kiểu cái
trong cái ID tất cả ID phòng này em một
cách đ một cách như này
và phòng 3 rồi đúng không đó Thế là xong
đấy còn à đây một cách Còn không thì các
bạn có thể dùng là join l Joy để cả như
này x rồi đây sẽ add là đã đặt đ như
này on phòng đã đặt như th
này rồi
Where
Ờ cũng đặt chấm như
này x nun để nó
sẽ
đúng mà C chuy vấn anh ghi quá chuẩn nh
Và thậm chí là hôm trước tôi mới biết
được nếu mà khi mà ông truy vấn kiểu như
này này ông truy vấn kiểu như này là bản
chất là cái này trúng xấu thế rồi
đ Cái refactor này xấu quá Tôi dùng cái
refactor gần đây dùng cái này còn format
lại đẹp
cảnh
báo
đó
let
tí select này
thằng này cung cấp mà Tại sao Thằng này
bị lệch ấy nhỉ một cười v
ở đây mình không thấy là khi mà kiểu
select như này này bản chất là nó sẽ tạo
ra một cái t table xong mình sẽ đây dùng
explain ở đây sẽ
để ông cái
table cái table này này cái table phòng
đã đặt này này nó sẽ là một cái time
table để mình mình truy vấn tới kiểu rep
ài không nhớ lắm nhưng mà nhưng mà có
gần đây anh tôi khuyên thì nó là như này
ông thực tế cái này bản chất là ông vẫn
join vào mấy thằng này mà th ông sẽ có
thể giữ y nguyên lại với thằng này như
này đó sau đó thì cái đoạn We này này
ông muốn dùng cái đoạn này gì Đúng không
ông sẽ bê cái đoạn này vào trong cái on
này này Đấy en này như này và tựng dụng
lại được được ông x đạn ve đi đợ Tí
and
đây phòng đã đặt thì đây nó sẽ còn lại
là lep chy với thằng này
này nếu mà một khi l choy thì không phải
le choy luôn ở đây ng nữa đúng nhỉ Tôi
chưa thử vụ LP cho với tận hai bảng như
này không biết là như nào th sao le cho
thằng này lep cho thằng này nữa như le
cho thằng này phải khai báo cụ thể là on
một cái đã nhỉ on cái thằng này
đợi tôi một tí đặt
phòng đặt phòng ở đây sẽ
là cho đặt phòng thì ở đây là đặt phòng
chấm ID phòng
chứ phải là
à đây sẽ
Đúng rồi đâ sẽ
chid
Ừ như nếu thế không en được C này nhỉ
Không que được cái đoạn
này và ngày check in các thứ thứ như
này đó Uầy thế này tôi nghĩ là trông còn
phức tạp hơn đối với ông nà không biết
ờ và cái gắn phòng
là nun chạy được không
nhỉ bỏ đoạn này
đi mất xử bốn cái à Hai 4 n của tôi rồi
Ừ Chắc kiểu này không được
stor thôi reverse lại code thôi Ctrl
z ctr z Ctrl Z
nào
đấy chạy
không Đúng chưa Bởi vì 32 được đặt mất
rồi mà đy chạy mỗi đoạn này sẽ
biết đây 32 đã được đặt trong khoảng
thời gian này rồi đúng không thấy ngon
chưa Ô vẫn chạy được mà nhỉ Đây tôi gửi
cho ông ông Test thử nhá nhá Đây f
này
ông bắt trước cái cách debug như tôi vừa
debug ấy xem chạy được không
Uầy quay đi quay lại livestream hai
tiếng thô thôi lại chuẩn bị đến giờ nghỉ
rồi Ờ g nhỉ Hôm nay mình định dạy về
những cái gì mà bây giờ chưa xong nhỉ Ừ
ừ hôm nay thực ra dạy mỗi cách V Kí thôi
Nhưng mà mình còn chưa dạy về cái kiểu
clear cách các thứ thứ như nào cho buổi
sau mình sẽ nói tiếp về clear cách này
Thế đây hôm nay chỉ mới học cách
à set and
get đây sẽ là clear C này sẽ là liên
quan đến model obs
này
Mod are observe đy như
này không nhớ cách viết đâu thông cảm
đấy mod là mod even này đó mình sẽ chỉ
cho mấy ông với cái này mua đồ hay El
quầ ấ Tôi không nhớ nữa hay bị nhẩm hai
khái niệm này lắm hình như là mod đồ đấy
Ờ nhưng mà ừ ây quay đi quay lại chỉ dạy
dạy mấy ông về SQL cái lập
tức Lựng người xem giảm ngay kiểu không
hiểu cái gì cả không hiểu chuyện gì V
đang xảy ra cả ờ đây buổi buổi sau tôi
sẽ hướng dẫn cho mấy ông mấy cái này nhá
Còn buổi hôm nay hai tiếng rồi tôi nghĩ
mấy ông chẳng trụ được nữa đâu Thôi nghỉ
thôi tôi còn đi ăn tối nữa tạ biết mấy
ông nhá Nếu mà ông nào ở Hà Nội mai có
hứng thì có thể nhắn rồi anh em thm kèo
đi sự kiện th nhá Bye bye m